[Musique]
qualité de président du jury du prix de
thèse j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
monsieur florent mugnier qui a reçu le
prix spécial du jury en 2021
[Musique]
mattez part du constat que la notion de
collectivité territoriale est une des
plus connues du droit public et du droit
administratif en particulier et parmi
ces aspects les plus marquées les
collectivités territoriales sont
identifiés à des personnes morales de
droit public or ces entités que nous
qualifions aujourd'hui de collectivités
territoriales n'ont pas toujours existé
comme thème ni été identifiés à des
personnes morales de droit public par
exemple les communes et les départements
n'ont pas toujours reçu cette
qualification non pas qu'on aurait
refusé leur attribuer cette qualité mais
parce que ses qualités n'ont pas
toujours existé et donc n'ont pas
toujours été pensé et exprimer si vous
lisez les lois la doctrine ou la
jurisprudence du début du 19e siècle
vous pouvez observer qu'il n'y est
jamais question de collectivités
territoriales et de personnalités
publiques
l'une et l'autre ne paraisse ni
exprimable ni pensable de sorte que les
administrations locales ne semble pas
prédisposé à recevoir ces qualifications
aussi l'objet de ma thèse est justement
d'observer la naissance de cette notion
de personnalité juridique des
collectivités territoriales au-delà des
questions de régime juridique de
répartition des compétences de libre
administration de décentralisation
j'observe comment la notion de
personnalité juridique des collectivités
territoriales bien s'ancrer dans le
langage dans le discours dans les
conceptions des juristes tout en
soulevant des questions théoriques et
historiques profondes relatives au droit
administratif au droit des
administrations locales mais aussi à la
théorie de l'état et aux rapports de
l'état avec le local pour y parvenir il
m'a fallu identifier le processus le
cheminement ou plutôt la généalogie qui
a permis à ce que se forme l'idée
suivant laquelle les collectivités
territoriales sont des personnes morales
de droit public
[Musique]
oh